[Musique]
fini le costume de l'agent 007 au
service de sa majesté
durant quinze ans chan conneries va
revêtir le look d'un mentor au service
des plus jeunes
regardez le dans haute voltige il à la
barbe taillée
l'oeil vif le corps est plus lourd mais
l'esprit toujours aussi alerte il
incarne robert mc dougall un gentleman
cambrioleur spécialisé dans le vol
d'oeuvres d'art
il va guider et former une tenace
enquêtrice d'assurance qui s'est fait
passer pour une voleuse pour mieux le
coincer mais tout comme cette belle
jeune femme
le vieux baroudeur a plus d'un tour dans
son sac présenté en soirée de gala
d'ouverture au festival de cannes 1999
haute voltige a tout du film rassembleur
fait attirant une histoire bien ficelée
riche en surprises deux acteurs vedettes
dont la très glamour
catherine zeta-jones trois braquages
spectaculaires trois sites des paysans
dont les fameuses twin towers de kuala
lumpur en malaisie
vraiment aucun risque de s'ennuyer
d'autant que le tandem vedette joie font
le jeu du chat et de la souris et le
scénario offre jusqu'au bout un twist
plaisant pas étonnant que le producteur
réalisateur britannique fillol amiel et
rencontrer là son plus grand succès rien
de mieux
une faute voltige pour rêver oublier ses
soucis et se distraire en revoyant sean
connery
[Musique]